[Music]
okay so I delivered your ass to the
planetary yeah I gotta go I have some
spectrophotometry of post starburst
galaxies to analyze Oh bless you so much
maybe right anytime
oh no all right as always all right all
right thank so we're here we are in the
hall of the universe yes and we've got
people here who like work in the
universe and I see when I'm standing
right there I know that guy Carter talk
to us come on in here they're back from
where were you I was in Singapore
Thailand teaching in Cambodia I met the
Royal astronomer and somebody's Royal
astronomer here yeah I'm a royal
something according to my mom and my
wife astronomy doesn't measure into the
actual equation though so he's got one
of the coolest business cards ever ever
conceived right okay so what does it say
well it's a director of Astro
visualization which is a contraction of
saying the director of astronomical an
Astrophysical data visualization okay
but does anything in the world
advertise that director of astro
visualization I don't think so right
there you go you are the only one I
guess people one-of-a-kind we got it
here we got this is Carter Emery a lot
of a car but what it means it what it
means is I direct the space shows but we
also have the software development
currently nasa-funded it's a
collaboration with with Sweden it's a
collaboration with New York University
and also the University of Utah Wow data
visualizing the universe and its
dynamics so there were these 3d all the
way to the edge 3d to the end 3d da so
the dough moves digital universe is
natively 3d right and when you display
it on a dome and move through it it's
it's pretty much like the dioramas here
but in a sense animated and you're
really there to the measurable
quantities just to be clear just to be
clear we're not talking about the 3d
where you put on glasses and then don't
knock that I am going to knock it you
can't do that
I am gonna knock it oh ok because if
you're gonna have your stereoscopic view
right give you 3d and you did that in
the universe I've seen people do that
it's oh my gosh look at the galaxy it's
spinning right here in front of my eyes
the moment you do that the galaxy is
this big right that's true and Gaussian
or not this big they're bigger than this
we have freedom to move our eyes to
intergalactic scale and thus view the
universe that way so we can use like a
VR headset that sees but the point is is
that that the measurements are all
accurate and so forth but that the
experience is authentic in a sense of
what we've collected as as information
about the positions of stars and now the
brain gives you 3d because he figures
out a way to move through the data so
that there's parallax of the nearby
objects relative to the distant objects
and he knows how close to go to one
versus another so that you feel the full
three dimensionality of space but wait a
minute
without without making the galaxy be
this little heavy a toy in front so
you're saying that you're having an
actual 3d mapping to scale when you look
at it from your human perspective we we
if well I mean not real gonna scale is
it actually what you would see if you're
in space yes
and so in other words if you were to
flop a to Alpha Centauri yes the sky you
would see the Sun in the sky as we
please see the star Alpha Centauri in
this guy so anyway and we see it
accurately for a position that's that's
what the space shows are based in that's
the set by which we then that's how we
roll in our simulations that is amazing
so you'll get literally not literally
you can visually take a spaceship ride
through the galaxy inside of your
experience that was that was the major
difference between the old haven and the
new haven so as what was conceived in
the rebuild of this place was
essentially to do that go from a flat
star map to a 3d star meds that's real
Wow so here's the deal I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you to do something Neil will
turn we're gonna fade to black
right and when we fade to black dark
what I want you to give me just a little
something that opens the dark universe
hi
okay you go ready as we fade to black
never forget that all the drives this
universe is dark dark matter dark energy
the darkness in the still of the vacuum
of space
they pack up that was awesome